le ton est de plus en plus grave aux
États-Unis hier la Maison Blanche ne
cachait pas son inquiétude inquiétude
grandissante quant à une éventuelle
frappe nucléaire russe en Ukraine et ce
mercredi le New York Times se révélé que
des généraux russes ont évoqué à la
mi-octobre la possibilité d'une telle
attaque le journal américain se base sur
des sources au sein du renseignement
américain il affirme en tout cas que
Poutine n'a pas pris part à ses échanges
sur le terrain à présent les
affrontements se poursuivent dans le
don-basse mais aussi dans le sud on va
faire le point avec notre correspondant
à Kiev Gulliver crack bonjour Gulliver
les autorités rapportent des raids
autour de la centrale de zapporja c'est
ça
alors ce n'est pas la première fois mais
il semblerait que c'est un peu plus
grave cette fois-ci les câbles qui
connectent la centrale nucléaire des
aporisa qui je vous le rappelle est
situé dans la région de zapporisa la
partie qui est contrôlée par l'Ukraine
avec excusez-moi dans la partie contre
les par la Russie donc c'est une
Centrale qui est sous occupation russe
alors que la ville des aporisa elle-même
est encore sous contrôle
ukrainien sécable ont été coupés par les
frappes et donc l'approvisionnement en
électricité pour maintenir les réacteurs
de la centrale de zapporisa se fait
grâce à des générateurs qui fonctionnent
au diesel c'est générateur il y en a une
vingtaine selon energuatum l'agence qui
gère les centrale nucléaires en Ukraine
il y a assez de diesel pour faire
fonctionner ce système pendant une
quinzaine de jours seulement avant ces
câbles avaient déjà été coupés et réparé
alors il faut espérer ce sera la même
chose cette fois-ci mais bien sûr c'est
une situation qu'il faut considérer
comme très inquiétante puisqu'on a une
centrale électrique nucléaire sous
contrôle
occupationnel l'occupant russe
maintenant a déclaré que cette partie de
la région des aporisa est annexée et que
la centrale est en réalité sous contrôle
russe mais des facto se sont encore
d'après des informations les ingénieurs
Ukrainiens qui travaillent et énerguatum
l'agence ukrainien qui prétend être en
contrôle de cette centrale il y a un
grand écart entre ce qui desjourait
devrait être la situation et ce qui est
des facto la situation sur place
quels sont les nouvelles du front cette
fois autour de Carson
alors vous savez la contre-offensive
ukrainienne pourrait essayer de
reprendre la ville derrière sonne cette
seule capitale régionale
occupée par la Russie depuis l'invasion
du 24 février ce poursuit mais ils sont
encore à une assez bonne distance de la
ville elle-même l'endroit où ils sont le
plus près c'est à 25 km c'est entre
Herson et Nicolae ville tenue par les
Ukrainiens ça c'est en direction de
nord-ouest en partant des personnes mais
si on regarde vers le nord-est là l'île
de front est beaucoup plus loin de la
ville de Herson le long du fleuve Nièvre
les forces ukrainiennes sont encore à
une centaine de kilomètres de la ville
et c'est là qu'il y a des batailles
selon des blogueurs militaires russes
entre les Russes et les Ukrainiens qui
attaquent les Russes qui les repoussent
c'est là qu'il y aurait eu des
affrontements ces derniers jours les
Ukrainiens ne communiquent pas sur ces
affrontements là mais parle de leur
frappe plus à longue distance pour pour
essayer de couper la logistique russe
leur capabilité de traverser le fleuve
notamment mais aussi leur dépôt de
munitions et des soldats Ukrainiens sur
le terrain disent qu'ils envoient les
résultats puisque les Russes se tirent
moins et ils ont l'impression qu'ils
essayent d'économiser un petit peu parce
que ils doivent se rendre compte que
leur stock de munitions n'est pas sûr
d'être remplie derrière puisque la
logistique est mise à mal par ces
frapper ukrainiens
merci beaucoup pour ce point complet
Gulliver Craig en direct de Kiev pour
France 24